the next man who could become the
chairman of the House Intelligence
referenced him now if he becomes
chairman he's vowed to continue to
search for the Russian collusion that so
far nobody's been able to prove I'm
joined by former US attorney assistant
US attorney and Fox News contributor
Andy McCarthy Andy
now if shift takes control of house
Intel what might we expect specifically
I think we expect exactly what we heard
from your last panelist until Michele
called her out on it I think you know
what you're gonna get is you know let's
look at the Trump Tower meeting let's
look at the financing behind Trump's
business empire let's in particular look
at the financing of his of his real
estate aspect of his of his business and
of course they'll say they need the tax
returns for that and you know we'll be
off to the races that's what it'll be
for however long it lasts although I
think it'll be of great benefit
politically to the president but I don't
think the country will like it very much
well yeah I mean they'll always
overreach they're gonna try to tangle
everything up and in these tangential
issues that will not help a single
American have a job hold a job and raise
wages none of that's going to be
accomplished but there it's Pavlovian at
this point where the democrats say it's
like they're there at the gates and they
just want to you know rush the gates and
get this stuff done and you have to ask
you about a report that came out just a
few hours ago John Solomon's piece in
the hill about FBI officials and DOJ
officials who had been getting freebie
trips to various foreign destinations
and one of the chief benefit
beneficiaries of these foreign trips
freebie trips was Andrew Weissman of
course who's one of the most senior
people in the Muller investigation
what's going on there yeah this has
become a really big problem Laura I
wrote about it a few months back when it
came up in a financial fraud
investigation in New York this whole
idea of the FBI and the Justice
Department having this kind of
incestuous relationship with the media
were there trading information and
they're getting favors out of it they're
getting tickets to sports events they're
getting you know all kinds of benefits
out of it I don't know what they're
doing at the Justice Department but that
ought to be item one that they're
looking at now in the hill another great
piece by John Solomon Andy thank you so
much